happy holidays Merry Christmas happy
whatever it is that you celebrate but I
decided to put together a Christmas
album for you guys because such a great
singer and I have this amazing producer
Samantha who really helped me make this
possible so thank you to everyone things
which is amazing green screen studio
that I used you guys really made my
dream come true and I also realized that
while making this dream come true I
don't know any words to any person songs
ever hope you guys enjoy here's the
making of my non-existent Christmas
album this man throw are you ready yeah
ready
okay can I get a little take sound check
or something out check countdown oh
three kids just Joe whoever did it but
Samantha she's paying for studio time so
we don't have a choice
well it's not the correct music you
didn't give in your lyrics
I'm knowing these songs how am I
supposed to build any of these songs we
start with maybe another song but I'm a
little more familiar with are you ready
I'm ready are you ready its function
three Dave I don't know this one either
we do another one please
five six seven eight
snow melting snow I can't I don't know
he's wires you like send me some
freaking like lyrics calm crap can I
just at least read them no so many books
so frosty
he's got ice for noose Navidad Feliz
Navidad Feliz Navidad I definitely know
this one I'm not even in holiday spirit
anymore deck the halls entrance
how many days of Christmas well it's
really who actually knows the words
turning these songs first day of
Christmas my true love gave to me now I
don't know on the second day of
Christmas my true love gave to me don't
don't know sup guys so we're on set
we're about to dance me and Harry have
been preparing this dance the past two
days so nervous cuz I'm really bad at
dancing